I've had several people DM me lately
saying something along the lines of like,
my ex is acting really acting fucking crazy lately or, gosh,
what is going on? They always act like this around Christmas time.
Like they're co parent, they're.
Do, you know,
just the. The ugly ex that they don't like to deal with.
That's what they do this time of year.
They are unable to cope when they're not the center of attention.
And the holidays are inherently a time of year
where they're not the center of attention.
They just can't be. There's so much fucking shit going on.
There's concerts and school
and presents and wrapping and parties and this and that.
There's so much going on,
it's really hard to make them the center of attention.
And they lose their ever loving fucking mind,
throw little fits or find read they're sick
or they're having some major issue that needs to take precedence.
You know, something's happening at where there's just.
They find some way to make themselves the center of attention
because they cannot handle it.
And unfortunately, the only way to do that around the holidays is to. It.
It has gonna have to be fucking huge and fucking dramatic
and a big fucking deal. So if you're confused or if that's like
what goes on in your life this time of year,
that's why instead of continuing the cycle,
it's maybe this could be the last year,
and then you Just break the cycle.